all right guys bang-bang we're gonna get
a couple of people in here Jesus this is
incredible
six trillion dollar stimulus package is
what they're saying is gonna happen
right now I don't even understand how we
got to this point so quickly it seems
like literally just a week ago two weeks
ago people were talking about literally
last Sunday 700 billion dollar
quantitative easing plan we're gonna go
by five hundred billion dollars worth of
Treasuries two hundred billion dollars
worth of mortgage-backed securities all
of a sudden this Sunday there's word
that there's a potential two trillion
dollar stimulus package coming down the
pipe and then out of nowhere BAM six
trillion dollar stimulus plan being
floated as I've been saying over over
and over again for weeks now it had to
be five trillion or more it looks like
they're gonna go to six trillion and I
think that part of the crazy part of
this is remember last week the Fed's
balance sheet went up 356 billion
dollars it's the most increase in a
single week ever it went all the way up
to four point six trillion dollars and
so by adding another six trillion
dollars that would bring the Fed's
balance sheet to ten point six trillion
dollars think about this for a second
ten trillion dollars we say these
numbers like they don't even matter
anymore but ten trillion dollars we're
gonna more than double the Fed's balance
sheet and it's because they have to do
it this problems economic slowdown is
way bigger than anyone originally
thought right and when people were
saying 700 billion dollars was a lot and
then two trillion was a lot I kept
saying it's gotta be five trillion or
more it's gotta be five trillion or more
six trillion dollars is a big big big
number and it looks like that's gonna be
some through lending power and then also
some through injecting actual liquidity
into the market just absolutely not what
we're seeing right now completely
unprecedented rates down to zero
- emergency cuts between meetings and
now we're talking about a six trillion
dollar stimulus plan that would double
more than double the Fed's balance sheet
right this system is broken and they
have to do this to fix it it is a
horrible long-term decision horrible
long-term decision but it's absolutely
needed to fix the issue in the short
term we're talking about potentially
having ten plus million Americans out of
work in a 30 to 45 day period right
unemployment before this whole thing
happened at the end of February was
three point five percent about five
point eight million Americans were
unemployed all of a sudden we're talking
about potentially having 15 plus million
Americans unemployed in the United
States the only way that they can solve
this problem is by coming with trillions
of dollars six trillion dollars is the
number right now it's not finalized yet
it would not surprise me if it went up
even more from there we went from 700
billion last Sunday to two trillion was
the number they were floating around
this Sunday 48 hours later we're now
talking about six trillion dollars
tripled in 48 hours and on top of all
this the proposals that are floating
around as to why this has not been
passed yet there's all kinds of garbage
that's being thrown in these bills a
hundred billion dollars for NASA throw a
I saw 25 million dollars for cleaning
supplies in the for the Capitol building
literally we have people who are arguing
over how much money is gonna go into
cleaning supplies for the Capitol
building instead of getting American
businesses and entrepreneurs and
employees the help they need immediately
right we're talking about getting money
to museums and all this other nonsense
and pork that they're throwing in these
bills but they can't get a deal done the
longer they wait the worse the situation
gets and the bigger the stimulus number
gets so 700 billion last Sunday two
trillion wasn't over this Sunday we're
now at 6 John if they don't get a deal
done by the end of this week by Friday
we may see 10 trillion dollars be the
number that's how quickly this situation
is deteriorating most of the people in
this live chat are sitting their asses
at home American economy has ground to a
halt if you walk down the street in New
York City right now there's 50
60 75 plus percent of the places are
closed it's not just people aren't
spending money there's nobody at work
there's nobody earning a living we've
completely shut down the economy and so
six trillion dollars again if we wait to
the end of the week may not be enough
then either this is absolute insanity
and they have to do it there from a game
theory standpoint they have to do this
so as much as we don't like it long term
it's the only thing that's gonna solve
the short-term problem and they have to
hurry up so shoot some questions in the
comments here I'm gonna do my absolute
best to get through this I only got
about 20 minutes but I want to jump on
six trillion dollars current fed balance
sheet 4.6 that means we're going over a
10 trillion dollar balance sheet if this
thing gets approved it'll be a massive
leap almost immediately I don't think
that people really grasp the gravity and
how large of a number six trillion
dollars right all the money that the
federal government has on their balance
sheet is four point six trillion we're
talking about more than doubling that
almost overnight and they have to do it
this is incredibly bullish gold Bitcoin
real assets etc they are going to
overwhelm the system remember what I
said the US dollar continues to
strengthen and it gets stronger and
stronger and stronger and they were
bringing a water gun to a combat zone
they were literally talking about we're
gonna drop rates to zero oh here's 700
billion dollars the market just kept
dumping and kept dumping and kept
dumping it's because the dollar kept
getting stronger and asset prices kept
bleeding and they knew it they didn't
bring those monetary stimulus bombs to
the battle then all of a sudden you are
going to not be affected and that's what
we saw everything that they tried before
was not affected now they're talking
about six trillion dollars if this works
which is not even guaranteed if it will
if it works they've got to weaken the
dollar they've gotta [ __ ] them they've
got to flood the market with dollars and
they've got a weekend that dollars they
can stabilize prices and hopefully start
driving towards your recovery it's gonna
be really hard to turn the economy back
on but that's what they're gonna have to
try to do QE infinity QE forever QE
gazillion is literally the number
they're going for six trillion dollars
is insane if you had told somebody three
weeks ago that there would be a six
trillion dollar stimulus
package they would have slapped you
that's how ridiculous this would have
sounded three weeks ago we were talking
about being surprised last Sunday by
simply having interest rate cuts and a
700 billion dollars we have what is that
more than six seven eight X what they
did last Sunday
we're only nine days since then and this
is where we are it's absolute insanity
bill Polti what's up man
but QE forever for sure yes this is the
bull case for Bitcoin here's my whole
take on the Bitcoin situation we've got
interest rates at zero maybe they go
lower maybe they don't who knows they're
going to print money like we've never
seen before
more than double the Fed balance sheet
as they do this we're gonna run people
right into the Bitcoin having we're 50
or less days away from that Bitcoin
having people are going to realize
they're gonna flood the market with
dollars my dollars gonna get devalued
over time I gotta get out I gotta get to
some sort of inflation hedge or real
assets because all of these assets
prices are gonna recover an incredible
way and so when they go to do that fifty
percent of the incoming daily supply of
Bitcoin is going to get cut BAM gone
you're gonna go for 1,800 Bitcoin to
nine hundred incredibly bullish if
Bitcoin does not drastically increase in
u.s. dollar exchange value between now
and the end of 2021 the entire thesis is
invalid right that's what I truly
believe there is no better setup than
we've seen for Bitcoin to do what it was
built to do it was built in a crisis and
it is the thing that is likely to help
us survive this crisis but it is
absolute insanity that they're gonna
print six trillion dollars and they're
gonna dump it into the market and so if
we want Bitcoin to end up doing what we
think it can do it has to perform
between now and the end of 2021 that
gives you about little less than two
years you're gonna run into this Bitcoin
having in May you're gonna get six
trillion dollars printed and bitcoins
gotta explode in US dollar value or the
thesis a lot of people are gonna go back
and revisit what the hell is going on
let's see what else burn that's right I
can't I
you can't put enough birds in the
comment sections this is absolute
insanity how does the milkshake Theory
pan out with these types of stimulus I
actually nobody knows this yet I just
recorded with a Brent Johnson from
Santiago capital literally an hour
we're gonna release it tomorrow morning
at some point he's the guy who's been
pushing the milkshake theory the dollar
milkshake theory so he explains that he
goes over what he thinks is gonna happen
incredible conversation so go ahead and
listen to that on the podcast we also
had the Peter Schiff episode dropping
tomorrow as well
rising faster than coronavirus numbers
that's right literally the stimulus
package numbers are rising faster than
coronavirus cases it seems like absolute
insanity and here's a crazy part is
they're gonna put this money and when
they start to spend it part of the
stimulus is they're going to give money
straight to Americans it is UVI this is
universal basic income they can call it
whatever they want it's universal basic
income and whether it's on a debit card
whether it's through a digital dollar or
they literally write you a paper check
from Dinosaur Land and they mail it to
you when they give you this money
it starts out $2,000 $1,000 whatever it
is per month they cannot stop once they
get American citizens and Families
addicted to receiving a check from the
government there's no turning back
there's no way they're gonna be able to
turn this off and the numbers that
they're talking about in some of these
proposals is they're gonna send you a
thousand dollars a month every single
month throughout the crisis and then for
a year afterwards it's kind of like when
they talk about the repo markets right
we're gonna lend some money into the
repo market but it's only temporary it's
only for this week that is why for this
month there's only for these two months
now here we are eight nine ten months
later whatever it's been and they've
done unlimited that's what they're
talking about now unlimited money in the
repo markets right unlimited money in
terms of quantitative easing the number
one from 700 billion last Sunday the two
trillion this Sunday - now it's over
it's going to be six trillion dollars
what they're saying if they don't get a
deal done by the end of this week with
Masie tential in our number which would
be absolute insanity but it is possible
so we will see what else thirty trillion
I don't think we're gonna get to thirty
trillion but hey who knows this is this
is going at such a pace that I have no
clue what's gonna happen what's the
endgame I have no clue what the endgame
is here other than I know what I'm doing
personally I'm protecting my wealth
there's no way that I'm gonna be sitting
in dollars long term I actually think
that dollars could still strengthen in
the short term look at Raul Paul to look
at Brent Johnson a couple of others
there is an argument that the dollar can
strengthen in the short-term as we
continue going through those liquidity
crisis asset prices drop dollar explodes
but over a long period of time the
dollar is gonna get absolutely crushed
when you start printing six trillion
dollars like this so I just think that
this is the people just gotta wake up
right that this is not a drill this is
real we are talking about numbers that
have never been seen before and what
we're seeing is we're seeing the Fiat
experiment absolutely teetering on
whether it will survive or not right I
put a huge thread together and I said
look I don't know for sure if this
happens but I'm shocked at how many
people in the mainstream press and on
Wall Street are not talking about the
possibility that what we are seeing is
the end of the Fiat experiment since
1971 we went off the gold standard we
lost that sound money component to our
currency and now all of a sudden what
are we seeing we're seeing incredible
levels of volatility the highs get
higher and the lows get lower right you
get this huge spread of swings around
that volatility between the good times
and the bad times at some point it
becomes unsustainable if you got to
print six trillion dollars and you just
literally got to start handing money to
people good luck cuz I don't know what
the hell they're doing but this is
absolutely sanity and so we're gonna see
what happens but six trillion dollars is
a big big number let's see what else
here pom given the fact that the US has
largest gold reserves do you think they
can get away with this printing for
longer than we expect it's possible
don't forget Russia the largest buyer of
gold over the last decade I believe
other countries like China etc those
central banks buying up tons of gold the
US yes we've got a ton of gold reserves
as well look at some point the
conversation like a Peter Schiff right
who says hey we got to go back onto the
gold standard right that's the way out
of this for the fiat currency he's got a
point there you know obviously I'm
ultimately betting on Bitcoin ending up
doing very well coming out of all of
this you know throughout this entire
bear market over the last month or so
and kind of as price tip I've been
buying more and really the way I think
about it is I'm taking dollars and
taking fiat currency that is about to
get absolutely blasted and devalued by
the federal government and I'm
protecting it I'm getting it into an
inflation hedge type asset that's got a
fixed supply 21 million Bitcoin I can
prove that it scares I can prove that I
own it and I
prove exactly how many are in
circulation how many are coming online
I like the transparency I like the
protection that's what I'm personally
doing this is not financial advice don't
listen to me I don't know what I'm
talking about
but what I will tell you is that if
you're holding dollars over the long
time and they put and they go ahead and
print six trillion dollars good luck
keeping that value there's just no way
that you're gonna keep value in that
environment this is about seizing full
control they will not allow any
alternative form of cash that includes
cold this may be the time people begin
to switch the silver soon yeah I don't
know III hear the arguments I know that
people are super into kind of this whole
idea of the control etc all I know is if
you're holding dollars they print six
trillion of it your dollars become less
valuable that's gonna be absolutely just
nuts
so we'll see there let's see what else
what other questions you guys have
it's a trillion not a billion this is
insane this is really really important
one trillion dollars right one trillion
is if you take a billion and you add
three more zeros so a billion is a big
number right remember in the financial
crisis what they gave was a seven
hundred billion dollars I believe it was
in quantitative easing they're now
talking about six trillion that is
almost 10x higher 10x we had in the 2008
financial crisis what they're talking
about now it's not a trillion dollars
right they're talking about printing
more money than the Fed currently has on
its balance sheet four point six
trillion on the Fed's balance sheet six
trillion would be printed here
absolutely freakin crazy but here's what
I keep saying the Federal Reserve's
actually doing exactly what they need to
do because the problem is they're in an
absolute lose-lose situation if they
optimize for the long term there will be
incredible short-term pain and people in
the united states will get crushed they
have to provide a short-term solution
that's the only thing that they can do
and if they go to provide a short-term
solution it will be the wrong decision
for the long-term and that's what you're
seeing here is they're optimizing to
help people today but making a really
bad long-term decision they have to
they have no other choice this is the
system that we're in their job is
actually not to manage a currency their
job is to manage an economy the economy
just shut off we literally took everyone
in the economy for the most part and we
said go home go sit at home because we
have to stop the pandemic we have to
stop the virus and guess what that's
probably the right answer to stop the
virus
but what you do is you shut off the
economy in order to bridge the gap or
provide a band-aid for the economy then
what you gotta do is you gotta come with
so much capital tonight and funny we
just saw six trillion dollar number and
they didn't even agree to it yet it
could be more right it could be less but
my guess is that it's going to be even
more than that so we're gonna see let's
see do we have really have all that gold
when is the last time anyone has seen
evidence of that I'm not an expert on
how they think of who has the gold who
doesn't have the gold all I know is that
you can prove who's got the big coin and
so I have no doubt that the US has
incredible gold reserves I've no doubt
that other central banks around the
world have incredible gold reserves I'm
not one of these conspiracy theories
that think that you know people don't
have the gold etc it's possible but but
I definitely understand exactly how
Bitcoin works I like the transparency I
like the fact that you can prove who
owns what it's I think there's a lot of
value there so we'll see how that goes
if the dollar is crushed but all other
currencies are the same what will that
change the whole world has the same
problem yes this is a really important
point so this is like the argument of
relativity here right or the relative to
basement and so Brent Johnson from
Santiago capital and I we just record an
episode he specifically talks about this
in the episode essentially the idea that
if we're printing and everyone else is
printing it doesn't necessarily mean
that the dollar is going to get weakened
against everything else because if
everyone's printing the same amount then
everyone gets devalued the same and so
you still keep a strong dollar relative
to everything else asset price is the
same etc but it's really important to
watch how much is everyone printing
right and what's the relative amount of
quantitative easing that's going on or
the liquidity injection you got to look
around the world and see what everyone
else is doing because it is important on
a relative basis to see what actually is
gonna happen there what else here
alright five more minutes and I'm
jumping off I just had to jump on here
when I saw that six trillion dollar
number absolutely nuts the whole world
is sitting at home you're right that's
true there there
or some economies that are coming back
online now right I've seen in certain
cities in China they're bringing people
back to work etc but that's the way that
we're gonna stop this economic downfall
right you got to get people back to work
you want to solve the American economy
you've got to get people back to work I
understand that there's the virus I
understand that there's the pandemic and
we got to be smart about how we address
that it is killing people it is getting
people sick it can overwhelm the health
care system I understand all the
arguments but if you look at the pure
economic argument how do you restart the
economy how do you solve the economic
problem you get people back to work you
turn American businesses back on now
there that's a black and white answer to
a situation that's not black and white
obviously you've got healthcare crisis
going up and you got a financial crisis
going on you gotta find a problem or a
solution to the problem that operates in
the gray zone how do you address the
economic problem while still addressing
the healthcare problem I got some ideas
I'm actually gonna write about it
tomorrow in the newsletter but that's
the issue that people are being faced
with right now there's probably not one
right answer that's the thing people
need to understand we can all yell and
scream on Twitter all we want there's
probably not one single answer that is
actually the right one and so you just
got to understand that people are going
to have to kind of take the best of a
number of okay solutions and figure it
out
let's see important the Fed printing and
giving dollars to other central banks
all central bank's buying companies
global nationalism yeah look I don't
know kind of intricacies of it the feds
gonna print and give dollars to other
central banks to then by companies or
not I haven't heard that but what I will
say is we definitely need to watch you
know one of the most incredible things
was I was watching CNBC today for a
minute and literally I think that the
Boeing CEO on there and he's literally
saying that there wait there waiting for
the bailout it's just like oh yeah we're
family we're just gonna sit here and
wait for the bailout to show up like
what that's not capitalism right what
world do we live in where literally the
CEO of fortune 500 companies are going
on television and literally talking to
the politicians in Washington and saying
we're waiting for our bailout absolute
insanity absolute insanity no wonder
we're in a world where literally the
Federal Reserve's got a point six
trillion dollars to get us out of this
mess but that's what happens so what's
the next move would
401ks take the tax penalty cash out
early for security I don't give advice
go talk to financial professional if you
don't know one just DM me on Twitter I
can introduce you a bunch of them that's
thick or smart but ultimately here's
what ends up happening is the dollars
been strengthening asset prices have
been dropping incredibly fast they've
got to come with a monetary stimulus
bomb they've got to do it in order to
weaken that dollar and get these asset
prices stabilized and going back in the
other direction six trillion dollars may
be the number but they're gonna double
the Fed's balance sheet that quickly
watch out because I don't know if the
dollar can withstand and continue to
strengthen into something like that
polina just walked in which probably
tells me I need to go get a go get
dinner soon let's see what else I'll ask
for two more questions that I got to go
how are you protecting your wealth
example of us to follow police again I
don't do any examples I don't do any
advice all I could tell you is what I'm
doing with my I continue to take Dollars
and exchange them for Bitcoin I think
that bitcoin is going to be one of the
best inflation hedges coming out of this
financial crisis you've got interest
rates at zero you've got six trillion
dollars now it's a proposal to be
printed and then you're gonna run people
right into the Bitcoin having in may
fifty days away or so I just don't see a
more bullish situation for something
like this if it doesn't work you know
people ask me all the time when will I
change my mind about Bitcoin if we get
to the end of 2021 and we haven't seen a
material increase in the US dollar value
of Bitcoin I will go back and question
what has happened with Bitcoin of the
theses for Bitcoin I just don't see us
going from here a you know less than two
years away at the end of 2021 and not
seeing that massive increase on the US
dollar value so that's kind of how I'm
thinking about that let's see one more
question here see digital dollar will
not be coupled to gold and even if so it
wouldn't threaten Bitcoin yeah so here's
my whole thesis on the digital dollar
real quick and then I'll run so
everyone's asked me why do I think that
a digital dollar a digital wallet is so
important it's so positive for Bitcoin
essentially the way to think about this
is if the US government or a private
organization comes up with a digital
dollar and it is somehow incorporated
into everyday American life whether you
could pay taxes with it the government
can pay you in it you know you're
incentivizing some way to use digital
dollars etc what
ends up happening is everyone has to get
a digital wallet and what I envision
here is what let's say the ubi payments
that they're talking about right if the
government says that 330 million
Americans go get a digital wallet so
that we can send you the ubi payments in
a digital dollar I know it got taken out
of the bill I know but in that scenario
what would happen is you would onboard
tens of millions if not hundreds of
millions of people just in the United
States with digital wallets all of a
sudden you give them a fiat currency I
don't care if the digital dollar or it's
electronic in your bank account or it's
the paper money it still has the same
monetary policy it's just changing the
technology form factor and if all of a
sudden they give you that and you're
onboard into the digital world and you
realize there is the ability to take
something that is an inflationary asset
that is six trillion dollars being
printed and it's getting devalued and
you can move that wealth into a
deflationary type asset like Bitcoin
with a disinflationary monetary schedule
where you can protect your wealth I
think a lot of people start to educate
themselves and realize they can protect
their wealth and so we can get people
those digital loss I think it's
incredibly bullish to getting people on
board into the digital world and then
they can make that decision today it's
not very easy for people to go out of
the US dollar in the United States into
other deflationary assets or inflation
edge assets it's mostly investors who
are doing this the everyday American
doesn't own gold they don't own other
assets remember 50% or more of the
United States citizens don't have
foreigner dollars for an emergency
payment they live paycheck to paycheck
they're 100 percent of their wealth is
in cash and they don't have access to
these other things they don't have the
money for it they don't have access and
so we can onboard them to the digital
world it will be incredibly valuable so
I'm gonna stop there I hope this was
super helpful for you guys I'm gonna try
to do these a little bit more often what
better time than when they announced
they might print six trillion dollars
and more than double the Fed's balance
sheet on a Tuesday it's Tuesday by the
way we haven't even gotten halfway
through the week and we've already seen
Monday morning unlimited QE Tuesday
afternoon now we're talking about six
trillion dollars in stimulus
I can't wait for Wednesday I'll see you
guys tomorrow